Jayden's are so-called super species
they have existed and roamed the earth
millions and millions of years ago and
went into hibernation for some unknown
reason while some of these talents
re-emerged in the past most of them
stayed dormant until Ghidorah sound in
his Alfa call gong never bought to
answer him back anyway in this video we
shall list down the talents that were
killed or suspected to be killed by
Godzilla there are seven of DS on this
list but not all of them are from the
movies so let's get them starting with
number one XI Nomura XI numerous are
swarm parasitic Mew toes that evolved
and lived 250 million years ago back
then Nishino Mura landed on a small
island to feast upon the remains of a
large aquatic creature it failed to
notice Godzilla and was subsequently
blasted by his atomic breath the body of
the Shi Nomura fell into a fissure crack
and was trapped until 1945 when it
reached it was hunted by the g-man all
over the world it then divided itself
into two swarms but one part of the
swarm was killed on Monster Island in
1954 by Godzilla shooting it down with a
powerful atomic breath while the rest
was obliterated at Bikini Atoll by a
nuclear bomb by the United States
military hence this is the first
recorded Titan kill of Godzilla number
two Muto mail the Muto's name is an
acronym for massive unidentified
terrestrial organism the Muto's unknown
to have been developed from rock mutant
an pterodactyl to early monsters from
the development of Godzilla the male is
described as young growing and looking
for food before meeting with the female
so he consumes radiation to gain
strength when he encounters Godzilla for
the first time he reacts with hostility
and becomes defensive attacking him
whenever an opportunity becomes
available and invading when possible of
course during the battle in San
Francisco he was killed by Godzilla with
a massively powerful tail swing crushing
him against a skyscraper number three
the mutual female as a species the
Muto's are sexually dimorphic as there
are several differences between the
males and the females the female
Muto has two pairs of photons and a
smaller pair on her chest and it's much
bigger than a male Muto standing nearly
twice the height of the male and being
almost as tall as Godzilla as a team
both mules are powerful and able to beat
Godzilla down with their combined
strength but alone she was easily
overpowered by the g-man and was gravely
weakened by his first atomic breath she
was later killed by another of
Godzilla's atomic breath but this time
right through her mouth and decapitating
her head number four the muta prime the
fourth Titan to be killed by Godzilla
was another subspecies of the Muto's and
it was bigger badder and uglier than the
previous ones in reappeared into the
world a few months after the deaths of
the two mirrors the muta prime is nearly
identical in appearance to the regular
female mute oh except for several
notable differences the muta prime has a
hard and outer shell with razor-sharp
back spires on it large orange glowing
four limbs as well as several smaller
pairs of four limbs on her chest she is
the only Titan with a record kill
against another Titanus Gojira however
in 2014
her battle with the present Godzilla
proved disastrous for her as she was
killed with a massive nuclear pulse
emanating from Godzilla's dorsal plates
number five mark Jaeger the MOC Iger was
seen as a corpse on the study in Castle
Bravo after entering the station Mark
Russell stares at a gigantic creatures
head like it came out of a nightmare and
was told that it was another Titan
called
Mark Giga it looked as reptilian as
Godzilla but the resemblance ended there
the face was flat the eyes were facing
forward like a human and her nose was
located above the eyes
she was found frozen nearly Arctic
already dead from a fatal wound that
risks from the bottom of her neck to the
abdomen a wound that was caused by
something hot and fiery and also
underwater which would therefore point
out to the only culprit
yes Godzilla might have killed it with
his atomic breath number 6 and gira
species the 6th island kill is more of
an educated guess and you might say a
presumption but let me get to it and
I'll explain why in king of the monsters
and the rest of the team when in search
of Godzilla and discovered a gigantic
underwater Kingdom and this prehistoric
civilization worship and lived alongside
tyrants under Godzilla's benevolent rule
during their venture they discovered the
skeletal remains of Italian that kind of
resembles and Garris this tyrant appears
to be four legged dinosaur like that
combines the features of an ankylosaurus
as seen our Sara tops and a crocodile
but estranged things that it was dead
and since it was in Godzilla's lair it
might have lost its way
met the king and found itself in the
arms of an angel number seven Ghidorah
and yes the last and also the latest
item to be killed by Godzilla is none
other than the false King most to zero
standing at 500 feet tall and weighing
140 thousand tons coming in from another
planet
King Ghidorah he is an extremely
malevolent entity a three-headed dragon
that comes from space with an aim to
transform the earth and kill everything
else Ghidorah and Godzilla are pretty
much equals while Ghidorah might be
stronger on land and air he definitely
is powerless under water as seen in the
Battle of the course of Mexico
nevertheless when Godzilla transformed
into his burning form he completely
incinerated him with his nuclear pulse
and blasted the last head with an atomic
breath and with this we come to the end
of the list of the seven Titans killed
by most of us Godzilla subscribe and
share our videos and do check out our
other monster videos as well